rauchen ist die führende vermeidbare
todesursache
mit dieser unmissverständlichen
feststellung begründet oberstarzt dr
michael seith die von ihm ins leben
gerufenen raucherentwöhnung seminare
diese seminare sind ein angebot des
bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung und sport für seine
mitarbeiter im rahmen der
gesundheitsfürsorge
sie finden am truppenübungsplatz lizum
weilchen statt nach einer ärztlichen
voruntersuchung nehmen mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen des bundesheeres aus
ganz österreich an diesen seminaren teil
in locker gestalteten vorträgen werden
zuerst die nachteiligen wirkungen des
rauchens anschaulich gemacht den
teilnehmern wird die angst vor dem
künftigen nichtraucher dasein genommen
die vermittlung medizinischer inhalte
stellt die erste säule dieses seminares
dar
in einem abendlichen gespräch werden die
gewonnenen eindrücke verarbeitet schon
zeitig am morgen beginnt die wanderung
die schöne landschaft und die
körperliche anstrengung dämpfen die lust
zu laufen
es wird ein feuer entfacht die letzten
zigaretten werden verbrannt
eine handlung von starker symbolik
ehemalige raucher berichten ganze
beginnt ja eigentlich mit einer
untersuchung die vom kopf bis zum zählen
unter komplett durchgecheckt wird das
alles nicht gewaltig und das engagement
von dr sein server man merkt war ist von
anfang an in guten händen und er hat es
mit seiner leidenschaft große
anerkennung ehemalige raucher scheinen
mit ihrer leistung zufrieden zu sein
die zweite säule des seminars ist der
psychologische teil wo
bewältigungsstrategien und autogenes
training zum stressabbau geübt und
angewendet werden
wichtiges hilfsmittel ist das intensive
erleben einer gemeinschaft die ein
gemeinsames ziel anstrebt dazu gehört
auch gymnastik es gilt freude an
bewegung zu wecken und ein gewisses maß
an fitness zu erreichen
die anstrengende wanderung mit
schneeschuhen auf den müllberg führt die
künftigen nichtraucher auf 2400 meter
seehöhe dieses ausdauer und
krafttraining bildet einen teil der
dritten säule des seminars die richtige
ernährung ist zur erreichung des
gesteckten zieles der seminaristen von
großer bedeutung und stellt die vierte
säule des raucher in
seminar star ernährungsberatung und
sinneswahrnehmung gehen der verkostung
gesunden essens voraus auch in lungern
test zeigt wie wichtig es ist dem
rauchen abzuschwören
ein blut test zeigt erste positive
ergebnisse bei dieser wanderung werden
circa 600 höhenmeter überwunden
dieses erlebnis stärkt das
gemeinschaftsgefühl und lässt das
rauchen vergessen